let's jump over to the first story we
got here after you smash the like button
of course
high school kids in colorado
walk out of multiple schools after
refusing to comply with mask mandates
and here we can see one kid holding up a
sign that says my body my choice
interesting how that one works
this story from cassandra fairbanks
dozens of high school kids walked out of
a denver area out of denver area schools
on thursday after refusing to comply
with a mass commandant imposed on them
the thunder ridge high school students
held signs saying my body my choice and
told reporters that those who are scared
of the virus should stay home after
walking out of class around 9 30 a.m
they were joined by nearby middle school
students and their parents students from
legend high school in douglas county
also held a protest against the mandate
here we have a bunch of videos of people
walking out
the tri-county health department
announced earlier this week to require
all students to wear masks even those
who have been vaccinated the local cbs
affiliate reports that they also
prevented individual counties from
opting out of public health orders the
order took effect on september 1st and
is expected to remain in place for the
entire school year now here's what
here's what they have to say
quote i believe that masks they're
they've been going on they've been going
for mostly two years now this is okay i
believe that masks they've been going
for most of two years now this is going
to be the third year of my high school
career that's compromised i want a
normal high school career there if you
are scared you could stay home said
student austin knapp as they rallied
these people agree with me they hate
masks and i do too said another student
the denver channel reports that thunder
ridge high school students were joined
by ranch view middle school students and
their parents
quote there's enough parents and there's
enough scientific data to show otherwise
that this is just not a necessary option
that they have to take and there are
enough students to that feel the same
way said parent amy ellis now
i actually don't know all the did he
know why it's changed so much i honestly
have no idea i know there were some
studies saying they found limited
efficacy there were some studies saying
the real problem was being indoors
because of recirculated air and there
was recently a study that said yes
actually masks did reduce transmission
so i i'm not i can't give anybody advice
on this stuff because everybody claims
to have the science and i don't know but
i can tell you this when bannon said
parents would be mad
i don't know if he expected the kids to
get mad too and the kids to come out but
if the parents and the kids and this is
just one location you know um it's it's
cause for optimism we gotta get some
good news and this is a this is the
first time in the history of of
civilization
that we have a plague or pandemic that
seems to exempt children miraculously
right the bubonic plague didn't do that
black death
sars other other illnesses
sort of hit the population equally this
this for some bizarre reason has not
affected kids and yet we're punishing
kids like we are are we're treating them
like they are as susceptible as as
adults and it does seem bizarre it also
doesn't seem to hit people without
comorbidities which is very strange
there are kids who have died absolutely
but the number is very very small
relative to the highest risk factor is
over 40. and so if you look at the cdc
data it it drops down significantly i
think obesity was a huge factor the cdc
says around a third of all
hospitalizations are obese what i want
to know is at what point do you have
covid and then be considered infected
with covet because the virus can be
there not hurting you at all well then
are you considered infected at that
point yes semantically you're infected
right so there's actually a lot of
viruses people have all the time but
they're they're asymptomatic i was
reading about i was i was i was covering
the uh the ebola outbreak years ago and
zika and stuff that's why i actually
interviewed people at the cdc
and it was really cool actually they
explained how ebola is a terrible virus
not because it's like physically
terrible and people are like
but because
it's so aggressive that it becomes so
presentable that it stops its ability to
transmit
they said good viruses are the ones you
have every day that don't make you sick
because they've successfully infected
you without triggering your body's
immune response and they're not killing
you so they can perpetuate so
kobe's getting more intelligent as it's
evolving to delta which is less
intelligent isn't the right word or less
lethal but more in ineffective i think
cell says that's the general trajectory
of viruses
as far as i understand it at least it's
yeah it may be intelligent is the right
word but that is a good point basically
the virus is becoming more successful
right it's more transmissible and less
deadly which means more people are going
to get it they're they're going to
experience severe symptoms to a lesser
degree
but they're going to get sick with it
and that's that's basically the cdc was
saying to me that
there's a lot of viruses that don't
cause enough damage to harm you so the
virus goes on forever and spreads around
like crazy but you know covert in its
earlier stages was was a bad virus like
it was it was bad for its own you know
propagation you know yeah and i can
understand where these kids are coming
from because when you are
15 16
your your window of experience is is
very few years right um so every minute
that is lost feels like an eternity like
being a kid waiting for christmas
morning was forever right if you've gone
through all of your the second half of
freshman year all of your sophomore year
now you're beginning junior year and you
can't play a sport you can't go to a
dance you're still
i too would feel like i am losing these
very few precious high school years and
i'm stuck in a bubble i can see them
being protesting just just the other day
i looked at my watch and i'm like it's
september already like what's going on
i'm old you know so thirty-five wow
do you still even though we're old do
you still get nervous when you see back
to school commercials i saw on the other
day on tv and like my heart skipped a
beat like back to school and i'm like i
haven't been in school in 30 years and i
was like oh my god back to school i got
so uncomfortable 30 years old oh yeah
i'm old really yeah
are you gonna say how old we established
this last time i was here i am 11 years
older than you holy moly so you have
been in school for 30 years 40 uh well i
guess 20 something yeah okay because i
was like what are you 50 no but it feels
like 30. is that that was like 30 yeah
the one comment that really stuck out to
me in that article is if you're scared
you can stay home i thought that was a
really interesting point because i heard
a family member recently say that you
know they were explaining some of their
hesitancies to go out and experience
life and they said every time i go out i
have to be i have to be worried about
what's going to happen to me and that
just struck me so counterintuitive and
this kid's hit on something that's
really vital it's just like if you're
scared then you can stay home that's
that's on you well we've we've inverted
the script you know now it's like
if you're scared you're hurting other
people and we should be allowed to go
around being scared i mean
who didn't see this coming we had
stories from seven years ago about the
the the foofy neon safe spaces they're
putting in colleges where if you were
triggered by a lecture you could go
inside and sit in a bean bag and hug a
plushie yeah you think i'm kidding this
is real yeah they were like pastel
colors and then you could go to therapy
and they'd be like remember that video
where it's nicholas christoph christakis
i think his name is and i think this is
the incident where the woman says
college is not about fostering
intellectual you know right conversation
it's about creating a home and a family
in a safe community or something like
that and it's like no it isn't i
remember that colleges yeah and that
started as the the therapy dog during
midterms because you needed to comfort
that were the point now although that
probably doesn't happen because of
covert but we're at the point now it's
like ben shapiro's coming to campus well
we have to we have to shut it down like
i am and people will say real college
students college students how
embarrassing college students will say
like i am afraid knowing he's on campus
it's like well dude then you need to
just live in a closet the rest of your
life like if ben shapiro you know four
miles down the road at like whatever
hall giving a talk to the yaf kids has
you literally afraid
then then just you should end it right
now because you're never gonna survive
in this world isn't ben like five eight
yeah i'm not trying to i'm not trying to
be mean i'm just pointing out like it's
not a very intimidating one but to be
fair he speaks very fast he does speak
very fast so that triggers you yeah and
what triggers is that he will probably
like he'll outwit everyone in the room
five times over because he is just very
damn smart oh those were just about him
owning people oh my gosh that's so
so quick that's what they're scared of
exactly yeah like i gotta say when i
when i saw ben on uh uh real time i was
impressed
wow
yeah
i mean he's calmer than he used to be
too but then like when we were in
college i mean i i only did two years of
college i didn't graduate on college
dropout um when i was in college that
short time i mean we had noam chomsky
come to school we had
we had communists come and lecture and
none of us were like i'm so afraid
knowing that this person is here she's
like oh you don't want i'm not going to
go to that lecture yeah i think that
what they're really saying is that
they're triggered by him being there
yeah like they're not really afraid for
their life no i don't think so anyway i
hope you know what you know what
triggered actually you know what afraid
really means
but you guys understand what like a
trigger it actually is
it's a real term when someone has
post-traumatic stress disorder or you
know whatever you want to call it george
clown has a great bit on this yes i
think they got they got rid of the
disorder part of it now
so you know you go to war and you hear a
bang in the middle of the night you wake
up you're like what's happening and you
experience that for a long period of
time then you see your friends die and
then all of a sudden you're back in the
united states and a car back fires and
you break down you start sweating and
your heart's beating like crazy that's a
trigger a trigger for and you need you
need someone to help you through that to
come back like we're not in the conflict
anymore so
we've bastardized that now too just
things i find this this comforting are
now a trigger i mean even the rights
mimified it you're like oh the left got
so triggered by this do you think that
ben and others like him are like
triggering people like making them feel
like they're they're in second grade
again and it's that kid that just
keeps talking to them and saying either
making fun of them or saying mean things
to them and then they feel that when
they see ben because he's so like
poignant like straight through you
well it's funny that you say that
because i did have something i wanted to
interject that's not exactly on topic
but i i spoke with a military veteran
who he's 90 now but he spent 30 years
working with veterans that had ptsd and
he had no data but he had anecdotal
evidence when i spoke to him he said
chris 90 of these veterans that have
genuine ptsd it didn't come from the war
it came from their childhood
practice and that's what i said i'd
never heard anything like that but in
the 30 years that he worked with these
veterans he was just like it's what
happened according to him is that these
kids had ptsd in childhood because of
traumatic situations they were in and
the war just blew it up you know you
know and i never got back interesting
i've not i've not been in like you know
hardcore full-scale warfare with
airstrikes or anything like that i've
been in urban conflict i've seen people
lose their lives and shoot at each other
and there have been bullets flying past
me and i would not say i've ever
experienced anything beyond like there
was one point where car back fired and i
had like an adrenaline rush and then i
was like whoa i gotta calm down and that
was the extent of it and so there there
are a lot of people i've met in like
hostile trainings hustle environment
trainings and i've talked to about this
and they've explained that they've seen
the worst you could possibly imagine and
they don't have like negative impacts
from it like
you know i don't know i don't know what
that means but i think some people are
attuned to like make it through these
things without having you know like
issues or you know
post-traumatic stress disorder whatever
whatever it's supposed to be called and
some people are heavily impacted by it i
don't i don't know i don't know what it
is
i mean i've never heard that before but
i mean going back to to those kids
though who were protesting i mean more
kids pre-covet died every year from the
flu in school and and everyone's heard
this argument a million times we never
shut down for the flu but we didn't like
you found out your classmate had the flu
and it was like oh dude don't come to
school you're going to get everyone sick
but schools didn't shut down but we lost
hundreds of thousands of americans every
year to the flu
and it was just kind of understood and
kids were susceptible to that i i do
think it's fair to point out though the
the long-term effects of covid the
potential long-term effects are what's
worrying and and to be fair what what
they're saying about young people is
that they're a transmission vector so
the kids aren't the ones being impacted
but they're negatively impacting old
people and my response to this is like
since when do we have the young people
make sacrifices for the old people i
understand these are these are serious
issues and people are concerned and we
definitely don't want old people dying
we don't want anybody to die
but at a certain point i mean i look at
what happened in with fukushima in japan
when the old people went and volunteered
to go into the you know to the reactor
to like shut it down knowing that this
was the end of their lives but they were
saying things like i'm going to
sacrifice you know what i have left to
help the next generation and so what i'm
really what i really want to get to is
here is you know look i'm not a doctor i
can recognize that there are health
risks there are a bunch of stories about
like teenagers who lost taste and smell
for like a prolonged period i'm sure
that sucks but
you know i'm losing my train of thought
was i going to say oh yeah yeah the kids
the suicides that we've seen spiking in
certain countries
and you know whether it's it's one life
or a hundred there was a story of a guy
uh a guy i knew um acquaintance he said
he's a tech uh ceo his son killed
himself
because this kid's i think he was like
10 years old
and he spent a year in lockdown
basically solitary never seen his
friends life was stopped and i don't
think the adults realized what this was
doing to children psychologically that's
ten percent of his life experienced in a
house you can't leave you can't go
outside everything's shut down you can't
you you can't that's what happened and
eventually it's just like the kid
couldn't take it i was i was uh really
surprised to hear the story to be honest
because like the idea that these kids
were were you know pushed into that
frame of mind to me was crazy and their
parents are right there and
there's like ample opportunity for the
parents to be there with their kids and
but we see more and more stories about
this
adults can handle this stuff better than
kids can and that's what we've got to be
worried about obviously we don't want
diseases spreading and covet sucks but
at what point are we going to be like
the lockdowns destroying the economy
nursing home stuff that cuomo these
other governors did literally murdered
people how about we do the opposite we
allow the economy to function we put
some restrictions in place that protect
the elderly and the immuno compromise so
they're all you know taken care of and
then we make sure the nursing home the
illinois homes aren't dying and the kids
can go their life live their lives
without feeling depression and suicidal
thoughts and things well that was the
purpose of rushing the vaccine which i
know is now fda approved at least one of
them but the purpose of the quick
vaccine and operation
warp speed was to protect the elderly it
was for older adults it was for older
adults to say we don't expect you
grandma and grandpa to live the rest of
your your golden years in your living
room so let's get a vaccine that you can
get back into society
and that has gone from let us get a
vaccine to protect the vulnerable to
give your 16 year old in hell we don't
you said you don't know the long-term
effects of of of covid and i know renal
issues have come out now as a long-term
effect what is the long-term effect of a
vaccine that no one knows the long-term
effect of right thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl monday through friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and super
chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you